الان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث قالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
قوتي بلادها تتقدم في منطقه اوروجين
بمقاطعه دونيتسك وتمكنت من تدمير دفاعات
القوه الروسيه والحقت بها خسائر بشريه
اكبر بثمانيه اضعاف من خسائر القوات
الاوكرانيه حسب وصفها غير ان القوات
المواليه لروسيا نفت سيطره القوه
الاوكرانيه على البلده مؤكده ان القتال
مستمر في هذه المنطقه معنى الان من دونيتس
كمراسل الجزيره نور الدين غير ومن
سيلفيانسك مازن ابراهيم وابدا معك مازن
حول تضارب الانباء بشان ما يجري في هذه
البلده
نعم في الواقع ازدهار اذا ما قارنا
الروايه الروسيه والروايه الاوكرانيه يتضح
انه على طول الجبهه هنالك مكان محدده كل
طرف يدعي فيها تحقيق تقدمه او تحقيق نصر
ما ولكن من الواضح ان خطوط المواجهه
ومعارك الكرب والفر هي سيده الموقف من
خركات شرق شمالا وشرقا مرورا بيلوغانس
ودونياس وصولا
عمليا ما يجري حديث عنه حاليا بين الطرفين
مجموعه من النقاط الملتهبه وكل طرف يدعي
تحقيقه مكاسب فلنبدا بكوبيانس في محيط
كوبيانك في مقاطعه خاركير تلك المدينه
التي باتت عنوانا للهجوم الروسي المضاد
اليوم كان هنالك حديث واضح من قبل المتحدث
باسم القوات الاوكرانيه في شرق البلاد
اشار الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه استوعبت
الهجوم الذي قامت به وتقوم به القوات
الروسيه طيله الفتره الماضيه وهي تمكنت من
صد هذه الهجمات ملحقه فيها كبيره وبالتالي
الحديث في كوبيانس عن ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استوعبت
الصدمه الاولى التي لحقت بها من خلال هذا
الهجوم الذي شنته القوات الروسيه في هجوم
في مواجهه الهجوم المضاده التي كانت قد
اطلقته القوات الاوكرانيه قبل شهرين ونصف
بالانتقال الى مقاطعه يمكن الحديث تحديدا
عن مجموعه من المحاور الملتهبه سواء في
جنوب اخ موت القوات الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن
تقدم لها في تلك المنطقه وان كان هذا
التقدم لا يرقى الى مستوى الوصول الى تخوم
المدينه تحديدا من جهتها الجنوبيه
وبالتالي الحديث هنا عن تقدم على المستوى
الاوكراني ولكن من الواضح ان خطوط الجبهه
لم تتغير بشكل كبير خلال الايام الماضيه
فيما يتعلق في تلك المنطقه اما بالنسبه
الى اوروجين تلك المنطقه في مقاطعه التي
تقول القوات الروسيه بان القتال ما زال
يشتد فيها هنالك الان تاكيدات اوكرانيا
بان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت من الدخول
اليها والسيطره على اكثر من موقع والحقت
خسائر كبيره على مستوى القوات الروسيه هذا
الامر ينسحب كذلك ايضا على مستوى حيث تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه بانها تنفذ هجمات على
اكثر من محور محاوله اختراق الخطوط خطوط
الدفاع الاولى وهي تشير بالفعل الى انها
تقدمت في احد المحاور على مستوى التصريحات
الرسميه يمكن الاشاره الى ما نقلته اليوم
وتحدثت عنه نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
الذي قالت بان القوات الاوكرانيات تحقق
تقدما في اوروجين وانها ايضا تلحق اضرارا
كبيره على مستوى المعدات والقوات البشريه
للجيش الروسي فلنتابع
نحن لا نتقدم فقط في اولى جيمي بل ندمر
دفاعات العدو ونقلص من امكانياته القتاليه
لذلك لن نقيس النجاح بمقدار الكيلومترات
المحققه فقط ذلك ان مجرد التقدم في ظل
الظروف الحاليه يعتبر نجاحا كبيرا علما ان
خسائر العدو اكبر بثمانيه اضعاف من
خسائرنا في الشرق واكثر بخمسه اضعاف من
خسائرنا في الجنوب
اتحول الان اليك نور الدين القتال ايضا
يشتد في محور كوبيانس ماذا في التفاصيل
هو القتال يشد في محور كوبيانس وكذلك في
المحور الجنوبي من دوني ونتحدث عن اورجينا
هاته المدينه التي اعلنت القوات
الاوكرانيه السيطره عليها ليتبين بعد ذلك
ربما الروايه التي كنا تحدثنا عنها
بالسابق بان هناك قتال يدور ما بين القوات
الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه لم يحسم الامر
هناك فعلا هناك دفع كبير للقوات
الاوكرانيه من اجل السيطره على هذه
المنطقه اذا نحن الان امام الروايتين
الروايه التي تقول بالسيطره الان الجانب
الاوكراني ربما يتراجع عن هذه الروايه
لاجل الروايه الروسيه التي تقول بان
القتال لا يزال مستمر لكن كذلك عسكريا
الجانب الروسي يتحدث على ان هناك دفع
للقوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه هذه المنطقه لان
السيطره على اوروجينا ربما سيؤمن نوعا ما
قريه هاته المنطقه التي كانت القوات
الاوكرانيه قد دخلت عليها لكنها منطقه غير
مؤمنه عسكريا وتقع تحت طائله النيران
الروسيه سواء على مستوى المصورات على
مستوى المد لا يمكن الحديث على انها
عسكريا تحولت الى منطقه رماديه لا يمكن
لاي قوه كيفما كانت سواء روسيه اوكرانيا
الاستقرار بهذه المنطقه اذا المدخل
بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه هو السيطره على
اورجينا لكن لحد الساعه يبدو ان القتال لا
يزال مستمر بهذه المدينه وبهذه البلده
الصغيره لم يحسم لحد الساعه ويبدو ان
التركيز على هذه النقطه من الجانب
الاوكراني هو محاوله حسم الصراع في الجبهه
الجنوبيه اي جنوب دنيتك في منطقه لكن
الانتقال الى المحاور الاخرى سواء في محور
او محور مارينكا يبدو ان الجانب الروسي
يحاول بشكل او باخر فرده معادلته العسكريه
بهذا المكان وهو ما ينعكس سلبا على داخل
المناطق هنا في دنيتك وسقوط العديد من
القذائف سواء هنا في مدينه دنيتك او في
مدن اخرى مثل المكييف او ياسين
نتاج الجبهه الملتهبه في مارينكا لكن
المعادله يبدو انها تختلف بشكل كبير
باتجاه الشمال والشمال الغربي نتحدث عن
لما نتحدث عن كوبيانس كون نتحدث عن هنا
تتحدث القوات الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه
بكامل قدراتها على انها فعلا تتقدم
بالخطوات وتسيطر وتقدم المساحات باتجاه
هاته المناطق من اجل السيطره عليها وهذا
ما اكده اليوم المتحدث باسم قوات الغرب في
الجيش الروسي
اثناء القتال في اتجاه كوبينس سيطرت
المجموعات الهجوميه على معقلين وموقعين
للمراقبه واستهدفت وحدتي مشاه في منطقه
اوتشان ومن اجل استعاده المواقع المفقوده
نفذ العدو خمس هجمات مضاده ضد مواقعنا وتم
صدها جميعا وفي سياق الاعمال الهجوميه تم
تدمير عدد من المدافع وثلاث مسيرات
شكرا لكما من دونات
ابراهيم شكرا لكم